advertencia aquí están podría cambiar
sus relaciones con rusia y occidente con
el nuevo primer ministro el parlamento
eligió este lunes
sharif para reemplazar a imran khan en
una historia de 75 años de política
nacional en la que ningún premier ha
completado su mandato khan dice que eeuu
está detrás de toda
esta conspiración se ha llevado a cabo
en connivencia con eeuu pero que tiene
eeuu contra mí nunca
históricamente pakistán se ha aliado con
potencias para contrarrestar el poder de
india en el sur de asia
primero fue eeuu pero las relaciones
cambiaron luego de que las tropas
estadounidenses mataron a osama bin
laden en suelo paquistaní esta nación es
la única musulmana que tiene armas
nucleares y su posición es clave al
compartir frontera con afganistán india
y china- icann una antigua estrella del
cricket lo sabe desde que fue electo
primer ministro en 2018 afianzó las
relaciones económicas con beijing y los
dos países han querido mediar en
afganistán en medio del histórico
respaldo de los paquistaníes a los
talibanes además la administración de
khan intentó revivir la diplomacia con
rusia congelada desde la guerra fría el
mismo día que los rusos comenzaron la
guerra en ucrania el primer ministro
paquistaní estaba en moscú con vladimir
putin mientras que sharif se inclina más
a occidente en medio de una sociedad
polarizada
requieren buenas relaciones con los
países occidentales pero hay mucho
resentimiento en las calles de pakistán
por la narrativa que ha construido imran
khan entonces el desafío inmediato es
como revivir esas relaciones
por eso la pregunta es como sharif se
acercará a occidente sin potenciar el
discurso de kan de que él es una ficha
de eeuu